Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans ce nouveau podcast.
Alors aujourd'hui, j'enregistre avec la petite caméra et je fais une vidéo un
peu rapide
parce que même si je suis en vacances, mes beaux parents sont arrivés chez nous
et
du coup je ne vais pas avoir beaucoup le temps de faire des vidéos.
Du coup, j'en profite pour faire une rapide vidéo avant qu'on sorte se promener
en ville
et aujourd'hui je voulais parler de Noël en France.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait Noël en France ?
Quelle est la tradition en France ?
Alors pour commencer, je vais parler de mon expérience donc ce n'est pas une
généralité
mais je pense que ça reste assez dans la moyenne de ce que les personnes font en
France.
Donc Noël bien évidemment, c'est une fête chrétienne mais il y a beaucoup de
familles
Athées qui font Noël juste par comme c'est assez traditionnel, on fait quand
même Noël.
Pour ma part, je suis agnostique mais depuis tout petit je fais Noël, ma
grand-mère était
catholique donc j'ai toujours eu l'habitude de faire Noël.
Premièrement, en général, Noël, ça commence juste après Halloween, donc
Halloween le
31 octobre et dès le lendemain, on commence à voir apparaître en ville des
décorations,
des décorations de Noël et il commence un peu à y avoir cette atmosphère.
Je pense que c'est aussi le moment où la chanson de Mariah Carey peut-être
commence
à redevenir populaire, il y a une statistique qui montre les recherches Google
de la musique
de Mariah Carey et à chaque fois vers novembre, mi-novembre, ça recommence à
exploser.
Donc c'est vraiment là, je pense, le lancement de Noël, c'est-à-dire quand on
commence
à avoir les décorations dans la ville avec des guirlandes, des lumières, etc. ou
même
dans les magasins avec des sapins de Noël, des pères Noël, etc.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment le début de cette atmosphère de Noël et après petit à
petit,
on se rapproche de plus en plus du jour de Noël donc le 25 décembre.
Une autre tradition qu'on a, c'est aussi, j'en avais déjà parlé, mais c'est le
calendrier
de l'avent, c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir une sorte de calendrier, souvent c'est
avec
des chocolats, et pour chaque jour de décembre, on va ouvrir une case qui
correspond au jour
pour manger un chocolat et ça jusqu'au 24 décembre, jusqu'au réveillon de Noël.
Donc ça c'est pareil, c'est quelque chose d'assez ancré, c'est quelque chose
d'assez
commun.
En général, c'est plutôt pour les enfants, mais personnellement j'ai 31 ans et
je continue
d'avoir des calendriers de l'avent, mais ça permet un peu de pas faire monter la
pression
mais ça permet de vraiment se mettre dans l'ambiance et d'attendre avec
impatience
les fêtes de Noël le jour de Noël.
On a aussi quand on est petit, en France, on a tendance à faire des listes de
Noël,
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait une liste et en général, normalement on dit que cette
liste
il faut envoyer au Père Noël.
La liste en fait c'est, on écrit ce dont on a envie, ce qu'on veut comme cadeau.
Cette année, je veux ça, je veux des Lego, je veux des Playmobil, ce genre de
choses
et en général, les parents nous disent, il faut être sage toute l'année pour
pouvoir
envoyer sa liste au Père Noël et du coup quand on est petit et qu'on écrit ou
que
nos parents nous aident à écrire notre lettre au Père Noël, on commence toujours
par
dire bonjour Père Noël, cette année j'ai été très sage et j'aimerais aussi
beaucoup
avoir ce tout nouveau Lego ou ce jeu vidéo etc.
Et du coup ça, après on l'envoie normalement au Père Noël donc en Laponie mais
bon c'est
aux parents qui vont faire les courses après selon ce qui est possible parce que
quand
on est petit, on n'a pas tellement la notion de l'économie, du pouvoir d'achat
etc.
Et d'ailleurs aussi quand on est petit, il y a souvent, bon, à la télé il y a
beaucoup
de pubs de Noël pour plein de jouets etc.
Et il y avait aussi, moi quand j'étais petit c'était des magazines avec plein de
jouets
et en général on prenait ce genre de magazines et on entourait ce qu'on voulait.
Après c'est pareil, ou on découpait pour coller dans notre liste mais bon après
c'est
pareil c'était pas systématique, bien évidemment.
Ensuite il y a aussi tout ce qui est les films de Noël, souvent à Noël sur les
chaînes
de télévision française il y a beaucoup de films qu'on dit de Noël qui repassent
à la télé.
Alors bien sûr il y a les films purement inspirés de Noël comme par exemple Love
Actualy.
Ça se passe à Noël donc il y a toute cette atmosphère, il y a aussi l'étrange
Noël
de Monsieur Jack par exemple et donc tout ça, voilà, c'est des films de Noël
entre
guillemets.
Mais à côté de ça il y a aussi les films qui ne sont pas forcément de Noël mais
qui qu'on aime bien regarder plusieurs fois à Noël par exemple les Harry Potter,
les Seigneurs des anneaux, ce genre de films où une fois par an on se les
re-regarde et
c'est toujours très agréable.
Il y a aussi le sapin de Noël bien évidemment donc le sapin de Noël en général,
bon moi
quand j'étais petit on avait un vrai sapin c'est-à-dire qu'on peut acheter
beaucoup
de vrais sapins dans les supermarchés à la période de Noël donc des arbres qui
sont coupés et qu'on place chez nous dans notre maison pour qu'on puisse le
décorer
pour après pouvoir mettre les cadeaux au pied du sapin.
Il y a bien évidemment aussi des sapins en plastique enfin des sapins
artificiels qui
permettent de ne pas couper tous les ans de nouveaux arbres et ça globalement en
général
ça dépend des familles mais nous on disait il faut à minima attendre le premier
décembre
avant d'installer le sapin et de le décorer donc ça en général on attendait
vraiment
décembre pour l'installer et pareil pour rentrer de plus en plus dans cette
ambiance
de Noël.
Et ensuite quand tout ça c'est prêt, quand on a fait tous ces préparatifs, quand
on a
envoyé notre liste de cadeaux, quand on a installé le sapin, qu'on a décoré le
sapin
avec des guirlandes, des boules de Noël, etc.
Là après on arrive vraiment au festivité donc en général il y a le réveillon de
Noël donc le 24 décembre au soir et il y a le 25 décembre donc le jour de Noël.
Depuis tout petit, moi on a tendance à faire le 24 au soir un dîner et le 25
midi un autre
dîner (déjeuner*).
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en France il n'y a que le 25 qui est vraiment
férié
donc souvent les gens travaillent quand même le 24 décembre.
Il y a aussi des personnes qui travaillent exceptionnellement le 25 décembre
mais en
général les entreprises doivent payer un salaire plus élevé parce que c'est un
jour
férié.
Donc selon le travail de chacun, parfois les familles ne font que le 24 soir,
parfois
seulement le 25 midi ou le 25 soir un dîner le 25 décembre.
Mais du coup nous en général on avait des vacances et donc on faisait un repas
en
famille le 24 soir pour le réveillant de Noël et un autre repas toujours avec la
même
famille bien évidemment le 24 le 25 midi un déjeuner le 25 midi.
Et ensuite quand on est enfant il y a une grosse question c'est quand est-ce que
le
père Noël passe parce que bon il y a toute l'ambiance de Noël mais je pense que
quand
on est enfant on a surtout hâte de pouvoir ouvrir nos cadeaux et d'avoir ce
qu'on a
commandé entre guillemets sur notre liste et ça il y a plusieurs écoles il y a
plusieurs
façons de faire.
Il y a des familles en fait où le 24 soir donc pendant le réveillant de Noël on
va
dîner etc et à la fin du repas on va mettre les cadeaux sous le sapin et on va
les ouvrir
à minuit par exemple.
Ça c'est quelque chose qui aussi ça dépend vraiment des familles donc ça peut
être assez
commun la question c'est comment faire en sorte d'avoir le père Noël qui vient
déposer
les cadeaux.
Pour ma part quand j'étais petit on ouvrait les cadeaux le 25 décembre matin et
alors
il y avait un peu cette magie de Noël où on se réveillait le matin et il y avait
tous
les cadeaux au pied du sapin on voyait vraiment tous les cadeaux et on se disait
vraiment
le père Noël est passé mais c'était une vraie torture puisque le 24 décembre au
soir
il fallait s'endormir et du coup comme on a vraiment hâte d'ouvrir nos cadeaux
comme
on a vraiment hâte d'être le lendemain matin personnellement j'étais dans mon
lit
et je me disais il faut que je dorme il faut que je dorme il faut que je dorme
etc sauf
que je n'arrivais pas et du coup c'était souvent une nuit un peu d'insomnie
jusqu'au
moment où on arrivait à dormir et en plus c'était un peu particulier enfin
c'était
une ambiance un peu spéciale parce que mes grands-parents habitaient toujours en
région
parisienne et du coup nous on allait en voiture chez mes grands-parents et après
le 24 au
soir on dormait tous les cousins-cousines dans la même chambre donc c'était
vraiment
une ambiance très familiale donc je me rappelle de ces entre guillemets insomnie
à espérer
m'endormir le plus rapidement possible pour le lendemain pouvoir ouvrir mes
cadeaux et
souvent d'ailleurs le lendemain matin on avait tendance à se réveiller très tôt
et à attendre les parents pour ouvrir les cadeaux les parents eux ont tendance
quand
même avait tendance plutôt à beaucoup manger et à boire un peu trop donc c'était
une deuxième c'était une deuxième phase où on devait attendre impatiemment pour
ouvrir
nos cadeaux et après il y a aussi quelque chose
qui est assez courant c'est qu'en général en france on a quelqu'un qui se
déguise
en père noël pour amener les cadeaux donc le 25 matin c'était pas hyper courant
mais
par exemple quand on fait noël le 24 décembre au soir le réveillant de noël en
général
il y a un adulte qui va se déguiser en père noël pour amener les cadeaux donc il
faut
qu'il y ait un parent et souvent quand on est enfant on ne sort en même pas compte
qu'il
manque quelqu'un on est juste choqué par le père noël surtout qu'il a souvent un
gros sac avec beaucoup de cadeaux donc c'est aussi des moments assez
particuliers en général
les enfants ont peur du père noël ils veulent les cadeaux mais ils ont quand
même peur
de ce vieux monsieur qui débarque dans une maison avec un sac rempli de cadeaux
mais
voilà maintenant maintenant que ça c'était vraiment quand on était enfant
maintenant
qu'en tant qu'adulte c'est un peu pareil on fait le repas le 24 au soir le
réveillon
de noël cette année on va faire un repas le 25 décembre au soir donc un dîner
aussi
le 25 décembre tout simplement parce que pendant ces repas on a quand même
tendance
à trop manger à trop boire et du coup c'est pour espacer un peu pour profiter
quand même
un peu et après maintenant en général on ouvre les cadeaux le 24 au soir pendant
l'apéro
ou au dessert et on se donne nous même les cadeaux enfin on se distribue un peu
les cadeaux
et voilà peut-être un peu moins magique mais on garde quand même l'aspect où on
se retrouve en famille pour manger ensemble et pour passer du temps ensemble
donc voilà
c'était une vidéo un peu rapide je voulais quand même en faire une parce que
sinon
je n'allais pas sortir de vidéo cette semaine donc désolé si c'est un peu rapide
mais
voilà c'était une petite introduction au noël en France n'hésitez pas à me dire
comment ça se passe chez vous si vous faites noël et je vous dis à la prochaine
pour
une autre vidéo merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout